[Musique]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de pâte
à puce ne vous trompez pas compter bien
sûr vaudois serrait moi d'abord parce
que attention il vous manque un
[Musique]
patanok ce que je suis malade qu'est ce
que tu as ça tu en as pourtant pas
beaucoup mangé
il a mangé tous mes gars tous les
gourmands qui tu es puni c'est bien fait
pour ta raison ne nous en occupons pas
ce qui est agaçant comme ça que tu as ta
tuque
je veux tout de même lui faire une bonne
terme de foin non j merveilleuse tisane
de fleur d'oranger et moi j'ai quelque
chose de mieux
une dizaine de clous de girofle qu'on a
le meilleur médicament
lamia le mien le mien je suis pas malade
que je vais prendre le 3 alors comment
te sens-tu avant mieux par le patin
l'udc voulait tout faire
attachmate la patache banque mec alfonso
tu as des 103 pour voir le mélange de
thriller
nous avons proposé un philtre magique se
vouloir
quant à lui de vous qu'on range en
aquitaine
[Musique]
quel est le responsable de cette
incarnation moi j'entends faso tu
n'entendras pas longtemps dans un sac à
papier
[Musique]
enfin j'ai perdu ma force méfaits du
film ne dure que quelques midi et voilà
monsieur bougon au vca vite fabrice et
moi notre filtrant pendant ce temps
l'agent peu de temps chez moi où est
passé ce petit et frottez il a disparu
coté sur moi pour le retrouver
[Musique]
le foin des fleurs d'oranger et clous de
girofle fait prêt mata zut vient boire
des tisanes
j'espère que monsieur beaucoup il n'y a
pas encore attrapée ok ce qui facilite
vitaux vie
[Musique]
je meurs de soif
cette merveilleuse boissons m'a redonné
des forces
alou deux petits snacks en catastrophe
[Musique]
par des dossiers bourgon
oh on va regarder combien 3g vous qu'il
y ait de pata pêche il ne faut trop
pékin comptait bien sur vos droits au
hasard
claude a pas manqué
[Musique]